(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre o procedimento
para a venda do imóvel arrematado.
A gente já falou lá no módulo 2
como é que funciona a venda do imóvel
que você arrematou de forma financiada em um
leilão fiscal-judicial e já falamos no módulo
3 como é que funciona a venda do
imóvel que você parcelou em um leilão judicial.
Então aqui, a gente vai fazer um apanhado
geral da venda do imóvel arrematado em leilão
com a finalidade de investimento.
Você comprou em leilão com desconto e vai
vender ali de forma tradicional.
Como é que funciona esse procedimento?
Quando surgir um comprador para o seu imóvel,
você vai fazer com esse comprador um contrato
de promessa de compra e venda estipulando um
sinal.
O objetivo desse contrato é vincular as partes.
Falar que o vendedor quer, de fato, vender
para aquele comprador e falar que o comprador
quer, de fato, comprar aquele imóvel.
Quando você faz esse contrato de promessa de
compra e venda, depois vai ser realizada a
escritura de compra e venda.
Mas por que existe esse contrato prévio?
Para que fique estipulado um prazo para que
seja elaborada a escritura e, dentro desse prazo,
o vendedor, que no caso vai ser o
arrematante, vai levantar as certidões para passar segurança
para o comprador.
Em toda venda de um imóvel, uma venda
realmente feita da forma como ela deve acontecer,
o vendedor deve passar certidões para o comprador
sentir seguro e saber que, realmente, aquela operação
pode ser realizada.
Quais são essas certidões?
Primeiro, as certidões do imóvel.
A matrícula atualizada para provar que não existe
nenhum ônus, nenhum gravame que recaia sobre aquele
imóvel.
A certidão negativa de débitos de IPTU, porque
a gente já sabe que IPTU é um
débito próprio terreno, e esse débito pode acompanhar
o imóvel.
E a mesma coisa com as certidões negativas
de débitos condominiais, porque a gente também sabe
que débito condominial é um débito próprio terreno
e pode acompanhar o bem.
Então, para que o comprador não seja responsabilizado
por dívidas anteriores à compra, ele deve requerer
essas certidões por segurança.
E também os documentos dos vendedores com algumas
certidões.
Os documentos básicos, os documentos de identidade, CPF
ali do vendedor, do seu cônjuge, dependendo do
regime de casamento.
Se for uma comunhão parcial de bens, os
dois cônjuges precisam aceitar aquela venda, assinar aquela
venda.
Se for separação total de bens, aí não
é necessário o consentimento ali do outro cônjuge.
Certidão de nascimento, se a pessoa for solteira.
Certidão de casamento, se for casado.
E aí certidões de processos.
Processos criminais, processos cíveis, processos escravaristas, processo na
justiça federal.
E certidão negativa de interdições e tutelas.
Essas certidões aqui todas, elas têm o mesmo
objetivo.
Provar para o comprador que aquele vendedor de
fato pode dispor do seu imóvel.
Que não tem nenhum processo ali de cobrança
daquele vendedor.
Que pudesse ser necessário utilizar o imóvel dele
futuramente para pagar aquela dívida.
Que o vendedor realmente está em condições plenas
de vender aquele imóvel.
Essas certidões todas aqui a gente consegue em
praticamente todos os estados de graça pela internet.
Então seria só você acessar o site do
Tribunal de Justiça do seu estado.
O site do TRT do seu estado.
E levantar essas certidões dentro do próprio site.
Então é bem tranquilo né.
Alguns sites emitem as certidões na hora.
Outros sites eles pedem ali um prazo de
2, 5 dias para emitir a certidão.
Mas é bem fácil de levantar essas certidões.
Isso aí vai passar a segurança para o
comprador naquela compra.
Então contrato de promessa de compra e venda,
sinal, partes vinculadas.
Um prazo para levantar essas certidões.
E aí você mostrar para o comprador e
depois apresentar também ali no registro de imóveis.
Que está tudo certinho.
Que realmente aquele imóvel pode ser vendido.
E aí o registro de imóveis e o
cartório de notas que vai elaborar a escritura.
Vão saber que realmente aquele imóvel pode ser
vendido.
Quando tiver tudo certo você vai precisar procurar
um cartório de notas.
Para elaborar a escritura de compra e venda.
Se a compra for à vista.
Então você vai entrar em contato com o
cartório de notas.
Vai falar que você quer fazer uma escritura
de compra e venda de um imóvel.
Vai encaminhar a documentação para esse cartório.
Toda a documentação pessoal do comprador.
Identidade, CPF, comprovante de residência.
Para que o cartório tenha ciência.
E todas essas certidões que você levantou.
Para mostrar realmente para o cartório que aquela
venda pode acontecer.
O cartório de notas vai elaborar a escritura.
Comprador e vendedor vão assinar aquela escritura.
E depois a escritura vai ser encaminhada para
o cartório de registro de imóveis.
Competente por aquele imóvel.
Para que de fato ocorra transferência de titularidade
do imóvel.
Deixando de ser do vendedor.
O arrematante passando a ser do comprador.
Isso se for uma compra à vista.
Em compra financiada não existe escritura pública de
compra e venda.
E sim um contrato de financiamento.
Nesse caso aí o comprador vai procurar a
instituição financeira.
Com quem ele quer realizar aquele financiamento.
A instituição financeira.
Vai também pedir essas certidões do imóvel e
do vendedor.
Para comprovar que está tudo certo.
Para saber que realmente ela pode financiar aquele
imóvel.
Vai conceder o financiamento para o comprador.
E aí o que vai ser levado a
registro é esse contrato de financiamento.
O contrato de financiamento com garantia de alienação
fiduciária.
Vai transferir em primeiro lugar a propriedade para
o comprador.
Vai deixar de ser do vendedor pelo arrematante.
Vai passar a ser para o comprador.
E depois também vai ser registrada a alienação
fiduciária.
Com o comprador entregando em garantia o imóvel
para o credor fiduciário.
Tudo que a gente já estudou lá no
módulo 2.
Então é assim que acontece a venda do
imóvel que você arrematou em leilão.
E essa venda também acontece de forma tradicional
no mercado.
Uma compra segura de um imóvel.
Ela sempre tem que passar pela análise dessas
certidões negativas.
Tanto do imóvel quanto do vendedor.
Essa é realmente a segurança para o comprador.
Para ele saber que futuramente ele não pode
ser responsabilizado por alguma fraude.
Ali naquela compra ou por qualquer coisa do
tipo.
Que o imóvel de fato vai ser dele.
E vai passar para ele livre de ônibus.